paroles du monde c'est votre rendez-vous
avec l'actualité internationale sur
public sénat bonjour à tous ravis de
vous retrouver sur public sénat à suivre
ce matin sur notre antenne l'audition de
bruno le maire le ministre de
l'agriculture par la commission de
l'économie du sénat
cette audition s'est tenue mardi
après-midi et devant les sénateurs le
ministre a rappelé les mesures de
soutien qui ont été accordés par les
banques aux producteurs laitiers pour
soulager leur trésorerie
mais le ministre a également tenu un
discours de vérité en expliquant que
tout n'était pas de la faute de l'europe
qu'il fallait également moderniser
l'agriculture française sera d'ailleurs
l'objet d'un projet de loi bientôt
présenté par bruno le maire en conseil
des ministres enfin bruno le maire a
également livré devant les sénateurs sa
vision de la régulation du secteur
laitier qui doit accompagner la
suppression des quotas qui vous le savez
est prévue pour 2015 tout de suite donc
l'audition de bruno le maire bonne
matinée à tous sur public sénat
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je vais vous dire féministe combien nous
est agréable de vous accueillir au
niveau de la commission des affaires
économiques du développement durable et
de l'aménagement du territoire
vous voyez aujourd'hui vous êtes entouré
bien sûr des et sénatrices et sénateurs
qui font partie du groupe élevage et
l'ensemble de nos collègues qui veulent
bien participer à cette réunion alors
nous aurions préféré vous accueillir
dans d'autres circonstances peut-être à
l'avenir pour parler de la loi de
modernisation de l'agriculture
mais aujourd'hui nous vous auditionnons
sur la crise laitière j'ai pas la
développer ici parce que je crois que
vous la connaissez suffisamment déjà
jeudi dernier vous avez été amené à
répondre à quatre questions d'actualité
vous avez pu apporter certaines réponses
il m'est apparu naturel que dans le cas
de cette audition
mes collègues puissent vous interroger
individuellement après votre exposé les
orientations que vous allez pouvoir nous
donner
voilà ce ministre c'est en toute
simplicité que nous nous auditionnons et
je vous donne bien volontiers la parole
merci monsieur le président merci
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs de
votre présence ici dans cette
configuration un peu impressionnante ça
me rappelle ma leçon d'agrégation avec
un jury vaste et de qualité je voudrais
juste vous faire une petite présentation
très rapide et globale des choix qui ont
été faits depuis plusieurs semaines et
plusieurs mois par le gouvernement en
matière agricole de façon à remettre en
perspective les choix qui sont faits
également sur la crise laitière
ces choix ils partent d'un diagnostic
que j'ai eu l'occasion de formuler à
châlons en champagne qui est un
diagnostic que je maintiens mot pour mot
qui est que l'agriculture française
connaît aujourd'hui sa crise la plus
grave depuis 30 ans pourra donner des
chiffres pour argumenter sa si vous le
souhaitez ce qui est évident c'est que
pour la première fois dans l'histoire la
culture française depuis très longtemps
tout agriculteur ou presque sont touchés
toutes les filières ou presque sont
touchés et nous avons un mélange de
crise nationale de crise structurelle et
de crise conjoncturelle liée aux marchés
internationaux qui accentue la
difficulté de l'ensemble des producteurs
je suis allé à la réunion des jeunes
agriculteurs ja pas très longtemps en
saône-et-loire et une expliqué de façon
très concrète que dans ce département il
y avait trois productions classiques les
céréales le lait et la viande de
consommation et que depuis des années
lorsque ça allait mal sur une filière ou
sur une autre on se re faisait un peu de
revenus sur la filière voisine et que la
personne ne se faisait de revenu sur
quelques filières que ce soit parce que
trois étaient touchés en même temps donc
je pense qu'il faut mesurer la situation
particulière à laquelle nous nous
trouvons aujourd'hui et les
circonstances que nous avons à affronter
face à cela le choix que j'ai fait avec
l'ensemble du gouvernement est sous
l'autorité du premier ministre et du
président de la république
ces demandes âgées dans trois discours à
l'égard des agriculteurs articulé
évidemment autour de décisions concrètes
ces deux choix très concrets
le premier discours qui me paraît
important à tenir aux agriculteurs
français c'est un discours de solidarité
je pense qu'il est essentiel de faire
comprendre à tous les exploitants
agricoles français que nous pensons à
eux et que nous occupons concrètement de
leurs difficultés et mon obsession jour
après jour
chaque jour de chaque semaine c'est
d'essayer de trouver des solutions qui
ne soient pas des solutions pour faire
plaisir dans les journaux qui ne sont
pas des solutions forcément médiatique
mais qui permet de changer concrètement
la donne sur le terrain dans chaque
exploitation et c'est honnêtement ce
qu'il ya de plus difficile parce qu'on
peut toujours faire de grands effet
d'annonce il faut surtout que cela soit
suivi sur le terrain des faits concrets
dans des délais rapides
c'est le choix que j'ai fait par exemple
filière fruits et légumes en mettant en
place une assurance crédit à
l'exportation qu'elle est aujourd'hui
la difficulté majeure de la campagne qui
s'ouvre matière de fruits et légumes
c'est l'exportation des pommes et des
poires
le chiffre d'affaires la production de
pommes en france la moitié se fait
l'exportation cet été on n'a quasiment
rien exporté
on n'a quasiment rien exporté parce que
les marchés sont fermés parce que les
pays d'europe centrale et orientale qui
consommaient ne consomment plus de
fruits et légumes et parce que la russie
qui est un des principaux importateurs
n'importe plus en mettant d'ailleurs des
barrières à l'importation sur lesquels
je pourrais revenir donc l'urgence pour
une filière comme les pommes c'est
d'avoir une assurance crédit à
l'exportation qui permettent de faire du
chiffre d'affaires est de dégager des
stocks
ça c'est l'urgence donc nous avons mis
en place cette assurance crédit à
l'exportation
c'est juste un exemple pour vous donner
cette méthode l'administration de ce
discours de solidarité
même chose sur le lait sur le lait
j'aurai l'occasion évidemment d'y
revenir
il ya d'autres problèmes en jeu mais
l'urgence absolue c'est de faire en
sorte que nous apportions une bouffée
d'air à toutes les exploitations qui ont
le couteau sous la gorge
je rencontre des exploitants laitiers
tous les jours on voit même d'ailleurs
dans la salle que j'ai rencontré il n'y
a pas très longtemps que je salue au
passage ils ont le couteau sous la gorge
par conséquent il faut leur donner une
bouffée d'oxygène en matière de
trésorerie
ces décisions que nous avons prises
depuis plusieurs semaines notamment en
apportant 30 millions d'euros des doges
exploitation c'est la décision que nous
avons prise hier avec les banques les
assurances et la mutualité sociale
agricole
fin octobre les appels à cotisation la
mutualité sociale agricole vont tomber
dans chaque exploitation laitière de
france
ces appels à cotisation et sont
calculées sur les trois années passées
2008 2007 2006 ces années ont été des
années où le prix du lait a été plutôt
favorables notamment la dernière année
donc les appels à cotisations vont être
élevés et chaque exploitant laitier de
france va recevoir un appel à
cotisations de msa élevés alors même que
ses revenus ont chuté
d'où la décision que nous avons prise de
reporter l'appel à cotisation de fin
octobre à juin au cas par cas aux
exploitations qui auraient plus de
difficultés voire la décision de prendre
en charge à hauteur de 5 millions
d'euros ces cotisations pour les
exploitations qui serait le plus en
difficulté autre exemple de mesures très
concrètes avec les banques dans cet
esprit du discours de solidarité qui
doit être une fois encore fondées sur
les décisions concrètes à ma demande
les bords débloquer 250 millions d'euros
de crédits qu'elles pourront apporter
pour les fonds de roulement des
exploitations en privilégiant les jeunes
agriculteurs et les investisseurs récent
c'est à dire tout ce qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui des difficultés financières
les plus importantes puisque c'est ce
qu'ils ont investis ils ont acheté un
robot de traite à 120 mille ou cent
trente mille euros il faut de rembourser
aujourd'hui et au moment il faut de
rembourser il ya plus d'argent dans les
caisses
les banques pourront leur prêter 250
millions d'euros à l'ensemble
exploitant laitier le remboursement ne
commencera que un an après en janvier
2011 sans pénalités de retard et sans
intérêt supplémentaire et le
remboursement se fera à un taux
préférentiel qui sera plafonnée à 3 %
maximum et ces fonds seront disponibles
avant le mois de décembre et ces fonds
seront organisées de telle sorte que
chaque exploitant laitier pourra venir
voir sa banque qui examinera sa
situation de trésorerie et qui lui
donnera des indications sur la meilleure
façon d'organiser son fonds de roulement
à sept réseaux riz dans les années à
venir
ça c'est concret c'est immédiat c'est un
vrai geste de solidarité à la fois des
banques de la msa et de l'état qui lui
prendra en charge à hauteur de 30
millions d'euros une partie des intérêts
d'emprunt pour 2009 et je viens de noter
dans une dépêche qui tombait ya quelques
instants que les organisations
syndicales avaient indiqué que ces
décisions allaient dans le bon sens bien
entendu ça n'est pas suffisant mais ça
va dans le bon sens c'est le premier
aspect je crois essentiel de tenir un
discours de solidarité à l'égard des
agriculteurs français qui en trouvent
souvent le sentiment d'être délaissés
soit par les pouvoirs publics soit par
la société française dans son ensemble
le deuxième aspect c'est d'être capable
de tenir un discours de vérité
tout n'est pas la faute des autres
tout n'est pas la faute de nos
partenaires européens
il ya un réflexe parfois un peu trop
répandue qui consiste à dire c'est la
faute de l'allemagne de l'espagne c'est
la faute de la commission c'est la faute
de tel autre voisin si l'agriculture
française ne s'en sort pas moi je pense
qu'il vaut mieux être capable de
regarder les choses en face de tenir un
discours de vérité et de dire lorsque
les choses ne vont pas je donne juste un
exemple celui de la fille à des fruits
et légumes en a parlé très longuement ce
matin dans une réunion qui a duré près
de trois heures nous avons un coût du
travail pour travail saisonnier vous le
savez tous ici qui est trop élevé par
rapport à nos voisins européens
on peut pas accuser nos voisins euros
bien décidé d'être compétitif je pense
qu'il vaut mieux essayer nous mêmes de
faire un travail supplémentaire pour
être plus compétitif dans des
productions comme les fruits et légumes
ou 60% du coût du produit final c'est le
coût du travail
on ne peut pas avoir des travailleurs
saisonniers qui sont payés 12 euros de
l'heure quand notre voisin allemand les
payes 6 euros de l'heure où nos voisins
espagnols 7 euros ou nos voisins
italiens 8 euros donc nous prendrons des
décisions pour remédier à ces décisions
ça ne veut pas dire pour autant qu'il
faut pas se battre pour un minimum
d'harmonisation et d'équité européenne
bien entendu et on en a discuté là aussi
ce matin notamment dans le domaine des
phytosanitaires
je pense qu'il est très important qu'on
arrive à l'harmonisation la france est
mieux que ses voisins à des produits qui
emploient moins de sitôt ce militaire
pour arriver à mettre sur le marché des
tomates des fruits des légumes pour
respecter davantage l'environnement que
ses voisins d'abord valorisons ses
produits éthiques ton les de façon à ce
que le consommateur sache de quoi il
retourne
et puis allons vers une harmonisation en
termes d'utilisation de phytosanitaires
qui serait une harmonisation vers le
haut qui soit une harmonisation visant à
limiter l'utilisation des
phytosanitaires dans le domaine des
fruits et légumes
là aussi je me battrai dans ce sens là
mais ce discours de vérité sur la
nécessité de réformes structurelles
il est très important à tenir je pense
qu'il n'est pas responsable pas
raisonnable d'expliquer qu' aucun effort
ne reste à faire alors que nos voisins
ont pu en faire certains de ce point de
vue là je sais que c'est pas l'objet la
discussion aujourd'hui je veux juste
dire que le projet de loi de
modernisation de l'agriculture répond
précisément j'ai eu l'occasion d'en
parler longuement avec jean paul emorine
répond précisément à cet objectif là il
s'agit pas de faire une loi fourre-tout
catalogue qui prend en compte toutes les
préoccupations sectorielle des uns ou
des autres
il s'agit de prendre quelques décisions
structurelles sur des sujets majeurs qui
redonneront un élan l'agriculture
française notamment sera question la
compétitivité notamment sur la question
de stabilisation des revenus notamment
sur la question de la préservation du
foncier agricole qui est un enjeu majeur
p troisième discours que je souhaite
tenir après le discours de solidarité et
le discours de vérité
c'est un discours de perspectives tous
les agriculteurs que je rencontre sans
exception quelle que soit la production
dans laquelle ils sont quelle que soit
la région dans laquelle il se trouve et
je crois être allé désormais dans toutes
les régions françaises m'ont dit qu'est
ce que vous attendez d'un agriculteur
aujourd'hui
et qu'est ce que vous nous garantissez
comme organisations agricoles dans les
années à venir et je crois qu'il est
absolument indispensable de savoir
répond à ces questions là sur la
première question
on attend à peu près tout des
agriculteurs français et j'estime que
cela mérite et notre reconnaissance et
des financements nécessaires à côté on
n'attend pas d'un agriculteur français
je pense qu'on aura l'occasion d'y
revient à notre discussion qu'ils
produisent à un prix qui soit le plus
bas possible par rapport à des
concurrents internationaux comme la
nouvelle zélande pour le lait ou le
boeuf pour l'argentine
parce que si nous allons dans cette
direction là nous abandonnons tous les
autres objectifs de notre agriculture
qui sont tout aussi essentielle 1 la
sécurité alimentaire de la sécurité
sanitaire
3 l'aménagement du territoire
4 le développement durable tout cela
nous l'attendons de nos agriculteurs
aussi et ça mérite une reconnaissance à
la fois en termes politiques et aussi en
espèces sonnantes et trébuchantes sur
les aides que nous leur apportons parce
que si nous tenons à discours
exclusivement économiques aux
agriculteurs en l'enduisant produisent
et au coût le plus faible possible pour
que le produit sur le moins cher
possible pour le consommateur bien dans
ce cas là pour être très concret pour
les élevages par exemple le demandons
leur de mettre des hormones dans les
bleus de production de ne pas mettre
leur lisier sous containers en inox dont
chacun un coût de plusieurs milliers
d'euros de ne pas mettre le bâtiment aux
normes
de tous les décès dans des stalles de
production plutôt galère bout c'est plus
cher à produire et engageons-nous dans
une voie qui est une voie très
différentes
ça c'est la première chose deuxième
élément il est impératif
je veux terminer par là parce que c'est
à mes yeux aujourd'hui le combat le plus
important impératif de gagner la
bataille de la régulation européenne des
marchés agricoles
je le dis avec beaucoup de gravité parce
que j'ai entendu avec parfois surprise
et un peu de déception aussi de la part
de certains responsables politiques des
critiques sur le thème la france n'agit
pas suffisamment pour la régulation
européenne des marchés
là je dois dire que les bras m'en
tombent je pense que la démocratie c'est
pas échangé n'importe quoi entre les uns
et les autres s'est échangé des
arguments raisonnables fondée sur des
réalités et des fêtes qui permettent de
constater un désaccord et d'essayer de
se rapprocher la france a été le seul
pays à l'origine de la régulation
européenne des marchés le seul
aucun autre pays la souhaitait à
l'origine se battre pour cette
régulation
depuis des années nous avons fait un
choix qu'est celui de la dérégulation
des marchés agricoles
on a pensé que c'était le bon choix on
s'est aperçu petit à petit que ce
n'était pas forcément le meilleur des
choix
seulement il a bien fallu un pays pour
lever le doigt autour de la table et
faire deux garçons mal élevées pour dire
désolé mais là je crois qu'on va dans le
mur
ce pays là ça a été la france en juillet
qui a dit il faut faire marche arrière
notamment sur la question du lait nous
avons rédigé un projet de texte portant
régulation européenne du marché du lait
je suis allé le présenter à berlin avec
mon homologue
ilse hagner qui a accepté de le co
signer et d'en faire un texte
franco-allemand ce texte nous l'avons
ensuite présenté aux différents états
européens au cours du mois d'août puis
début septembre
tout cela remonte donc maintenant à
plusieurs semaines nous l'avons présenté
au conseil des ministres de
l'agriculture où il a reçu un accueil
il faut le reconnaître assez mitigé on a
eu une douzaine d'états qui ont été
prêts à nous rejoindre et la commission
nous a expliqué l pour sa part qu'elle
estimait que ce texte était nulle et non
avenue et la présidence suédoise nous a
expliqué qu'il ne fallait pas s'engager
dans la régulation européenne des
marchés est certainement pas du marché
du lait que le choix avait été fait de
renoncer aux quotas et qu'il fallait
laisser les quotas c'est tard sans rien
mettre à la place une semaine après
devant la dégradation du marché du lait
et l'effondrement des prix et les
difficultés des producteurs
nous avons eu un nouveau conseil des
ministres et culture cette fois un
conseil dit informel en suède
nous avons réussi à convaincre deux
états supplémentaires
l'espagne et la république tchèque
par ailleurs la commission après
plusieurs entretiens avec mariann
fischer boel a accepté de considérer qu'
il fallait effectivement examiner des
propositions franco allemandes en
quelques choses ont bougé sur les deux
fronts par ailleurs le parlement
européen notamment le président de la
commission agricole du parlement
européen a accepté également de
reconsidérer les positions initiales et
a admis que la régulation était une
nécessité et qu'il fallait donc la
construire ge était lundi en pologne
hier nous avons convaincu la pologne qui
est un état très important aujourd'hui
en europe de nous rejoindre dans la
régulation jeu sera en italie cette
semaine
j'espère que l'italie qui avait une
position très négative au départ pourra
bouger
où en sommes-nous très exactement et
quelle est exactement la stratégie
française
nous sommes à quelques voix de la
majorité qualifiée qui est à 255,6
l'italie qui pèse 29 voix comme vous le
savez au conseil nous rejoint nous avons
la majorité qualifiée ça veut dire que
nous pouvons imposer la régulation
européenne du marché du lait s'agit pu
en discuter
il s'agit de l'imposer j'ai proposé
également que nous ayons une réunion
extraordinaire
sai des milliers d'années culture en
soulignant que face à la crise actuelle
était urgent de trouver un point de
sortie
le point de sortie il n'y en a pas
d'autre le point de sortie politique de
la crise c'est un conseil des ministres
extraordinaire des ministres de
l'agriculture qui admettrait que la
régulation européenne du marché du lait
est nécessaire et qu'à partir du moment
où on a fait le choix de l'abandon des
quotas
il faut mettre une autre régulation en
place si nous arrivons à ce résultat et
j'espère que nous y arriverons
d'ici quelques jours aux alentours du
début du mois d'octobre
ce sera le résultat de deux mois
d'intenses négociations diplomatiques à
l'initiative de la france
ça c'est la réalité des fêtes
c'est la réalité du fait j'ajoute que si
on en tire les leçons pratiques
la france a pris l'habitude depuis des
années et c'est aussi un des choix
stratégiques que j'ai fait en arrivant
me serre la culture de constituer des
minorités de blocage au conseil des min
l'agriculture la minorité de blocage
99 voix dont constituent une minorité de
blocage
et dès qu'on nous demande de faire
quelque chose d'évoluer sur les
subventions de faire bouger les aides à
la pac ont dit non 99 assez facile à
constituer moi ce que je souhaite c'est
que la france première puissance
agricole européenne reprennent le
leadership agricole européen pour
reprendre le leadership agricole
européen c'est pas des mots c'est des
voix ça veut dire qu'il faut pas c'est
une situation où on récupère à chaque
fois 99 voix à une situation où on
récupère à chaque fois
255 voix c'est à dire la majorité
qualifiée avec laquelle sont prises des
décisions au conseil des ministres de
l'agriculture
c'est un changement stratégique majeur
mais c'est ça qui nous mettre en
position de force pour la négociation de
la pac 2013
si nous restons à regoûter sur nos
positions sur des minorités de blocage
nous seront systématiquement débordé par
nos partenaires européens
voilà le point très générale que je
voulais vous faire
r discours de solidarité discours de
vérité mais également discours de
perspectives pour l'agriculture
française qui a tous les atouts pour
réussir dans les années à venir
merci monsieur le ministre
comme vous l'avez rappelé dans un
premier temps des mesures
conjoncturelles pour exprimer la
solidarité de la nation vis-à-vis des
éleveurs laitiers je crois
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons affaire à des
entreprises qui ont beaucoup investi et
me paraissait nécessaire d'avoir des
mesures conjoncturelles sur les mesures
structurelles
vous évoquez bien sûr votre démarche au
niveau de l'union européenne
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on peut pas
concevoir l'agriculture sans avoir une
démarche européenne
par contre pour ce qui concerne la loi
de modernisation de l'agriculture vous
l'avez évoqué choix que nous avons à
travailler pour redéfinir un cadre assez
simple de l'avenir de notre agriculture
soit diverses propositions pourront être
faites de façon à prendre en compte la
notion d'entreprise que représente
l'agriculture d'aujourd'hui
moi je ne vais pas être plus long parce
que c'est surtout pour que mes collègues
puissent vous interrogez les données
tout de suite la parole à gérard maillet
qui préside le groupe d'études élevage
qui est peut-être le plus à même de
poser une question dans un premier temps
mais alors yannick botrel de vous
inscrire si vous voulez poser des
questions sur la bête bien sûr un
monsieur ministres sont très très
heureux que vous soyez parmi nous cet
après midi et je me joins aux propos de
jean paul emorine justement pour vous
remercier
et puis aussi remercier aussi de
l'action que vous conduisez au niveau
européen pour faire en sorte de trouver
comme menez de le dire
une majorité qui permettra de queuleu
que l'europe revoit ses positions dans
ce domaine là puisque nous n'oublions
pas que les causes déjà sont venus
décision européenne de tout ce qui était
les aides au stockage de tout ce qui
était un petit peu laissé à vau-l'eau le
marché les marchés agricoles lé marché
laitier en particulier on rappelle quand
même je crois qu'il faut pas oublier de
le dire
l'agriculture ce n'est pas une
production comme un autre on ne choisit
pas les quantités que l'on peut faire la
météo y est pour beaucoup et beaucoup
d'ailiers et on sait qu'un agriculteur
un ou deux pourcent de manque de
produits les prix sans flamme 1 ou 2 %
d'excédent les prix deviennent
catastrophiques
donc on sait aussi que tout cela
l'agriculteur ne peut pas le décider lui
même que ce soit les rendements laitiers
que ce soit la production des vaches ou
world et des arbres fruitiers
s'ils vont produire ou pas donc quand
même il faut que l'europe comprenne bien
que l'agriculture ce n'est pas un bien
comme les autres qu'il doit y avoir
absolument des systèmes de régulation et
vous l'avez rappelé je crois que je te
souhaitons tous bien sûr que nous
allions dans ce sens là deuxièmement
aussi je crois que l'année dernière on
peut dire quand même que la dgcrf nous a
pas aidés en nous a pas aidés je crois
qu'il faudra pas peur de le dire parce
que aussi on sait aussi que
l'agriculture essayait de s'organiser
avec bien entendu la transformation
voire la commercialisation est plus que
des menaces ont été faites en dix ans
les règlements européens ne le
permettent pas donc c'est vrai aussi qu
on a à laisser un peu aller tous ces
accords est qu on a vu dès ce moment là
une bien moins bonne organisation des
agriculteurs bonjour et pas non plus
qu'on montre trop du doigt les
agriculteurs dans ceux là dessus puisque
ils ont été menacés de sanctions de ce
côté là donc sa première question irait
dans ce sens là justement parce que je
crois que c'est important vous avez
beaucoup parlé de l'organisation
européenne mais aussi de l'organisation
nationale aujourd'hui est bien quand on
saura t-il et de l'organisation entre la
transformation mais personnellement je
pense qu'il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin que la transformation fois la
commercialisation
je crois que on a peu parlé aujourd'hui
de la commercialisation
aujourd'hui la crise du lait dit mme
howard
si vous avez trouvé que les prix du lait
dans les grandes surfaces ont baissé
jusqu'à présent voit toutes les
informations j'ai demandé qu'on fasse
des relevé est justement là aussi on
aimerait bien aussi que
ce qui a été fait avec le contrôle des
marges avec tous les bris dont
prédécesseur avait lancé je vais le
barnier luc chatel et bien que là aussi
on montre quand même à la grande
distribution que ce contrôle des marches
de pâques des mots mais quand même aussi
qu'on est complètement une transparence
parce que quand même nos entreprises de
transformation que ce soit dans le
domaine laitier ou dans les autres
domaines de l'agroalimentaire voit dans
d'autres produits industriels
aujourd'hui civis tellement une pression
de la grande surface que ce n'est pas
elle je crois qui aujourd'hui sont en
situation les plus mirobolantes
cherchons où est aujourd'hui la plus
value importante c'est quand même bien
au niveau de la commercialisation
je trouve que vous n'en parlez pas
beaucoup et on n'en parle pas beaucoup
moi personnellement tous les stages en
immersion qu'a demandé le président du
corps du sénat je les ai toujours fait
soit dans de la grande surface sont des
entreprises qui livrent à la grande
surface
j'ai toujours été bon pour essayer de
voir quels étaient ses articulations
donc je crois aussi monsieur le ministre
il faut pas du tout oublié ce domaine là
et que aujourd'hui je vous fait tout
petit calcul vous augmenter les prix des
produits alimentaires de 3%
quand vous savez dans les produits
alimentaires le peu qui va au prix à la
production agricole dans beaucoup de
domaines que ce soit dans des
charcuteries ou dans un yaourt
vous verrez bien car on donne une marge
considérable aux produits agricoles à la
production
si on veut bien calculé aussi cela je
trouve qu'on n'en parle pas et que là
aussi une possibilité j'aimerais bien
qu'on regarde un petit peu au niveau de
la commercialisation et de la mise en
marché parce que je crois que ces dames
cela est important
ce que je voudrais aussi posé comme
comme question bien sûr c'est sur la
compétitive quelle agriculture on veut
on va en parler bien sûr avec la loi
d'orientation
parce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez à faire
je sais que vous c'est difficile c'est
difficile pour votre prédécesseur au
niveau de l'europe avec l'europe du nord
qui veut beau des structures beaucoup
plus grande
je crois en élevage et puis aussi nous
qu'on veut quand même maintenir un
maximum d'acteurs sur le territoire que
sont les paysans
je voudrais quand même rappeler aussi
avant qu'olic qui sont ici peut-être que
tout saison pente est il ya seulement 25
ans il y avait quatre cent trente neuf
mille producteurs de lait on en est à 97
milles donc vous voyez déjà que en 25
ans passés de 439000 à 97 milles est
tous ceux qui lèvent à descendre et
qu'on avait 7 million cent mille vaches
c'est qu'on en a plus de trois millions
sept cent mille donc ça aussi c'est
quand même un potentiel économique qui
n'est plus dans nos pâture je parle pas
des ovins je crois avoir dit à l'époque
ce que c'était heureusement que la
technicité des éleveurs a beaucoup
amélioré puisque on ne sait vaches qui
se sont beaucoup moins nombreuses
puisque elle s'est donc plus de la
moitié - ont produit quand même
davantage
heureusement c'est pour ça aussi que
j'ai dû tout de suite moi j'étais
producteur de l'hers et mes fils sont
producteurs de lait quand je vois les
efforts qu'on a faits dans les
exploitations immense
quand je vois tout ce qu'on a fait est
que aujourd'hui des fois par fondu mais
l'agriculteur vous pouvez encore
diminuer vos marges bien c'est quand
même difficile on voit les prix des
carburants bien sûr on vient de voir
encore convient de reprendre maintenant
les primes d'équarrissage on vient de
voir les vaccinations pour la fièvre
catarrhale
et puis bien entendu aussi se dessine
encore quelques charges avec le grenelle
peut-être le prénom la république a bien
annoncé que la taxe carbone ne serait
pas supporté par l'agriculture mais
comprendrait bien quand même que il ya
quand même beaucoup d'interrogations et
vous le comprenez bien vous l'avez senti
sur vendant toutes vos visites un petit
peu sur tous ces points que je vais ni
donc pour en terminer avec des questions
j'en ai déjà posé une il y en a eu
d'autres que je vais poser celle de
votre prédécesseur avait décidé aussi de
médiateurs philippe brégaint de guénin
et pierre lepetit
est-ce que leur travail se poursuit
justement pour cette grande médiation
parce que je le rappelle je me répète un
petit peu commercialise production
transformation commercialisation
je crois qu'il faut absolument un qu'on
aille jusque là
dans les accords pour pour demain vous
avez aussi évoqué et nous y souscrivons
complètement le problème de l'étiquetage
avec le label france je crois que cela
est important mais vous avez vous pouvez
évoquer aussi tout ce qui est qualitatif
c'est la sécurité alimentaire la
sécurité sanitaire de l'eau demande du
râble
mais admettons que nos agriculteurs
françaises vont produire avec toutes ces
conditions c'est déjà ce qu'ils font
j'en ai parlé et c'est je crois encore
s'ils seront prêts à faire mais mais
faut-il aussi que demain de soyons sûrs
que les débouchés au prix de ses
produits
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure avec des
charges bien plus importante en terme de
main d'oeuvre qu'ailleurs on puisse
aussi encore vendre nos produits vous le
savez qu'aujourd'hui les études qui ont
été faites
je crois par des organismes compétents
ont montré que le coût de dans une
exploitation de 200 mille litres
le coût d'un ligue de l'est 7 313 euros
au jour par 2 3 313 la tonne excusez moi
ça va de soi
313 euros la tonne et et que aujourd'hui
les agriculteurs en sont à 2 193 et cela
sans parler du travail
donc c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on est
quand même un petit peu loin des
objectifs
et puis vous le savez aussi sap et
évoquer les veaux d'élevage dans les
exploitations aujourd'hui je crois la
direction régionale de l'agriculture de
franche-comté via ce serait de donner le
prix des veaux en 2007 en moyenne des
veaux de huit jours 139 euros
sans trop en 2008 au mois de novembre il
était vendu 49
vous savez aussi que c'est un problème
qui vient s'ajouter comme le prix de la
viande
donc quand même bien vous avez monsieur
le ministre une tâche immense
on a confiance en vous j'ai confiance en
vous je pense aussi beaucoup des
collègues autour de la table mais je
crois qu'on aura beau à jouer sur
beaucoup beaucoup de critères pour
essayer de redonner espoir aux
agriculteurs parce que jamais jurer
poncet même personnellement étant de la
profession que les producteurs de lait
sera les si loin dans les manifestations
ces jours
allemande désarroi est grand et on le
voit aujourd'hui même tous les
responsables professionnels sont tous
dépassés tant les gens sont angoissés
donc je crois qu'on a une crise vous
l'avez dit on à parements connus dont je
crois qu'il faut tous ensemble qu'on
s'attelle pas critiquer ma chercher les
meilleures solutions pour demain mais
merci mon cher collègue je voulais
rappeler mes collègues qui encore cinq
ou six demandes de parole avec le
président du groupe d'études élevage qui
avait droit à l'exposé des motifs et de
poser des questions aux ministres je
vous propose que nous passions peut-être
aux questions et puis après parce qu'il
y aura certainement des interférences
dans les questions et je crois que ça
pourrait peut-être faciliter vos répond
yannick botrel ministre le contre le
constat que vous avez dressé
beaucoup d'entre nous le fond et sur
l'analyse il n'y a pas grand chose à
dire
la crise elle est structurelle et
conjoncturelle dans un certain nombre de
filières liées à l'état du marché
nous en sommes d'accord avec malgré tout
un focus que chacun fait sur la crise
actuelle de la filière laitière qui ne
tient pas simplement qu'à un problème de
surproduction
je crois que dès le mois de mai
la question a été évoquée au sénat
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
rappel au règlement lors d'une d'une
séance ce à quoi nous assistons
aujourd'hui était éminemment prévisible
ce qui ne l'était pas forcément ça a été
cette grève du lait qui qui prend dans
certaines régions moi je suis un d'un
bassin laitier où il ya un grand nombre
d'éleveurs désormais qui font la grève
du lait et c'est vrai que c'est
complètement inhabituelle jusque là on
avait le droit à des mouvements
revendicatifs très fort parfois violent
mais de cette nature là nous ne l'avons
jamais vu l'ambiance est très lourde
incontestablement très lourde division
très fort tant qu'agriculteur désormais
mais qu'on retrouve dans d'autres
conflits sociaux entre grévistes et non
grévistes mais il faut pas minimiser ces
choses là elles me paraissent
extrêmement importante
et puis ce qui est extrêmement important
également c'est que les organisations
syndicales et singulièrement
l'organisation la plus représentative
n'est plus écouté aujourd'hui par les
agriculteurs y compris par ses adhérents
tout ça vient du fait que les gens ne
voient plus de perspectives et qu'il est
grand temps que effectivement on les
pouvoirs publics soient en capacité d'en
donner quelques-unes beaucoup
d'exploitations sont déstabilisés et on
se demande jusqu'à quel point
j'entends par là que vous annoncez un
certain nombre de mesures dont je ne
conteste pas le bien fondé mais avez
vous des éléments aujourd'hui en votre
possession pour nous dire que quand bien
même ces mesures seraient appliquées
combien d'exploitations ne se relèveront
pas de cette crise dans la filière
laitière
parce qu'on sait qu'il y avait déjà des
gens qui étaient mal avant que la crise
n'éclate et bien évidemment compte tenu
des circonstances et compte tenu des
pertes qui sont constatées aujourd'hui
on voit mal comment elle pourrait s'en
sortir parce que le fond du problème et
il a été évoqué le fond du problème
c'est la rémunération
il est clair que
au niveau de rémunération où on est et
quand bien même encontre actualiserait
on ne voit pas comment l'équilibré
économique des exploitations pourraient
être rétablis alors sur l'examen des
causes de la crise il y a d'évidence un
phénomène de surproduction et pour
autant il y a aussi les décisions qui
ont été prises et qui relèvent de soi
des politiques européennes soit parce
que c'est parfois comme mode de mettre
en cause l'europe
à certains égards soit aussi des mesures
qui auraient pu être prises au plan
national je vais pas m'étendre là dessus
parce qu'elles ont déjà été évoqué n'est
le début de la dérégulation
c'est quand on a commencé à dire en 2003
qu'on a les alliés à la fin des quotas
alors certes depuis il ya eu des
événements 2007 la crise au plan du
marché mondial là le
la nouvelle-zélande qui est un gros
exportateur le se trouve en situation de
crise les prix flambent
on relâche absolument toutes les
mécanismes dans la période mais on a vu
à un moment donné que on retrouve l
équilibre du marché donc je me suis
d'accord pour dire aussi que il tient à
très peu de chose est néanmoins on a
continué sur cette idée d'augmenter
l'autorisation de produire par un
pourcentage supplémentaire de quotas
chaque année tout en annonçant que en
2015 se serait terminée et puis aussi
dans ce système qui fonctionnait en
france sur la base d'un accord de
filière
grâce aux gones il est bien
l'intervention de la dgccrf est venu
singulièrement perturbé le paysage et
perturber les relations qu'il pouvait y
avoir entre les partenaires donc il ya
des causes qui tiennent aux marchés
d'autres qui tiennent aux décisions
politiques qui ont été prises et puis
d'autres qui tiennent aussi à des
mesures que l'on pourrait qualifier de
plus nationale alors aujourd'hui
j'entends tous les partenaires dire
qu'il faut retrouver la régulation
certains ne lisait pas il ya quelques
mois mais systématiquement dans tous les
discours désormais y compris d'ailleurs
dans celui que vous venez il exprimé au
nom du gouvernement on retrouve ce mot
de régulation d'évidence
c'est le bon sens on n'est pas dans une
production l'agriculture n'est pas un
système de production comparable à
certains autres on sait très bien qu'on
est sur des cycles longs que les gens
engagent des capitaux importants pour
pouvoir produire et que cela demande
comme je le disais un certain nombre
d'années avant de pouvoir retrouver un
retour sur investissement donc
aujourd'hui le mot régulation on
l'entend partout simplement
j'entends aussi les efforts que vous
avez entrepris ce faire en direction
d'un certain nombre de pays européens et
le mot europe aussi on entend les
recrues heureusement on l'entend partout
aujourd'hui alors qu'on attendait un peu
moins simplement on voit qu'on a affaire
à un certain nombre de pays qui ont une
approche extrêmement diversifié de la
production agricole et singulièrement de
la production laitière
il serait quand même intéressant que au
delà du mot lui même qui intéresse tout
le monde
on nous explique aujourd'hui sur quel
mécanisme on peut compter désormais pour
introduire un peu plus d'organisation
dans la filière laitière
quoique
autant sur le concept nous pouvons nous
ne pouvons qu'aller dans le sens de ce
qui a été dit autant sur la déclinaison
du concept on est resté un peu sur notre
faim et on souhaiterait bien évidemment
avoir un peu plus de précisions quant à
l'incidence sur la filière elle-même je
lui ai dit tout à l'heure moi je suis
juge ses sentiments et je le dis avec
beaucoup de tristesse que certain nombre
d'agriculteurs ne survivront pas à cette
crise les mesures vous les avez annoncé
pensez vous que ce sera suffisant et ne
faudrait-il pas que dans chaque
département dans chaque région il y ait
véritablement un regard plus précis
porté sur la situation des agriculteurs
merci mes chers collègues je demanderais
d'être moins longs sur exposé des motifs
mais posez vos questions plus rapidement
parce que le contexte choix que tout le
monde le connaît mais vous pouvez avoir
des questions un peu plus personnel la
pause est on sûr tout l'intervenant qui
va suivre c'est marcel deneux qui a
beaucoup de responsabilités dans la
filière laitière
une première chose pour mettre au point
président
je n'ai plus aucune responsabilité dans
la filière laitière gic g quelques
responsabilités de j'ai quelques
responsabilités dans l'interview mais
j'ai eu 30 ans de responsabilités dans
le piège chers collègues dangereux et
c'est justement ce que je veux vous dire
monsieur le ministre
tout ce qu'on dit mes amis moi je veux
partage vous arriver un moment où la
situation est grave on a rarement une
situation agricole à revenus dégradée
dans toutes les productions comme en ce
moment même les productions végétales
qui n'avaient pas l'habitude sont
dégradées vous arrivez au mauvais moment
n'est peut-être pas choisi votre moment
c'est vous qui êtes arrivé alors il va
vous falloir faire de gros efforts pour
dire les choses que les agriculteurs
comprennent et et notamment moi je veux
revient après tous mes amis
il faut affirmer qu'il n'ya pas de
revenus agricoles dans des marchés
désorganisée et qu'il n'y a pas de
marche est organisée
sur ne maîtrise pas le volume de
production après on peut discuter de
tous les maux quotas pas quotas contre
tout ce qu'on veut hugo poèmes de base
s'essuie gars si vous cassez marché en
ayant 1 % de volume de production en
plus bon alors dans la crise actuelle
dans toutes les choses qui ont été dites
valides mais dont il faut se rappeler
moi mon sentiment personnel c'est qu'il
ya crise que nous vivons en france
aujourd'hui c'est ce ce sont des
répercutons percussions un peu lointaine
mais pas si lointaine que ça de notre
politique d agrocarburants on mesure à
tout ce qu'on veut c'est clair que quand
on regarde bien eu les répercussions des
productions végétales serait production
animale
le prix de la viande prix des veaux tout
ça tarde bon alors on vous la dédie à 3
ans n'a pas pris les mesures qu'on
aurait dû prendre autre chose que je
veux dire monsieur le ministre puisque
j'ai quelques responsabilités dans la
viande je peux révéler des choses sans
qu'ils aient trahison de secret
professionnel
il est clair que nos amis de la grande
distribution joue un jeu particulier
moi je suis dans un groupe où nous
vivrons des marchandises ont fait 300
migrants steaks hachés par jour nous
sommes en pré étiquetage et il est
courant que nous changeons les
étiquettes sans que notre prix de vente
à nous soit changé sur des raisons que
nous ne comprenons pas toujours et quand
on est du côté des producteurs on est
quand même un peu étonné me dirais avec
des nuances d'un type qui est d'un type
de comportement qui a par une complicité
entre les pouvoirs publics et la grande
distribution
la position de la dgccrf de réné
dernière ne s'explique pas autrement
alors après on peut habiller comme aux
mains mais comme vous faites des
réunions de canton avec des adultes ils
sont de plus en plus doués l'information
d'économie politique passe et il faut
remonter une pente qui n'est pas facile
pour dire qu'on veut c'est bon alors
tout ça existe dans un climat global je
vais pas reconstruire la politique
agricole mondiale mais j'ai regardé
l'année dernière avec quelques amis dans
16 pays de vaud c d e
le revenu moyen des agriculteurs
twitter est au-dessous du revenu moyen
du pays c'est donc un type de politique
des pays développés conduite d'une
certaine manière nous voulons en france
nous y opposer il faudra que dire chirac
avait commencé à dire des choses
intelligentes il ya 5 6 ans au congrès
mondial des jeunes agriculteurs
on peut reprendre ce discours qui
réitère qu'il ya un problème de
confiance des agriculteurs qui vous
forme et employeurs je n'en dirai pas
davantage dans les choses que j'avais
noté jeudi pour notre ami bailly mais
aussi pour tout le monde
méfiez vous du côté gang âge de prendre
ces chip de diminution de producteurs en
nombre quand j'étais président de la
fnpl il y avait j'ai connu cinq cent
vingt mille producteurs cotisants dont
qu'il existait un et nous avons à ce
moment là mis des quotas laitiers quand
je dis nous lie et beaucoup contribué
pour 224 millions d'hectolitres de riz
pour la france nous sommes aujourd'hui
autour de 110 mille producteurs devaient
nous faisons toujours 224 millions
d'hectolitres de l'est autrement dit
c'est pas nombre de producteurs qui fait
leur production c'est le nombre d'étapes
et nombre de vaches et de ce côté là
monsieur le ministre vous aurez à vous
pencher encore sur la politique
génétique de ce pays
il y à ici ou là des détails à corriger
mais vous avez autour de vous un
excellent cabinet une très grande
administration qui vous faut écouter
écouter les agriculteurs essayer de
comprendre ce dossier il y a un très bel
avenir pour l'agriculture de ce pays à
condition qu'en soit sûr et qui est
perspective soit ouverte et je m'arrête
là il est clair qu'il n'y aura pas
d'avenir pour cette agriculture sans
organisation appelée gars comme vous
voudrez mais il faut une régulation
absolue alors on pourrait chevauchées et
à période qui s'annonce
si jamais on réussit au g20 à dire
qu'après tout faudrait réguler
l'économie capitaliste on pourrait en
profiter pour chevaucher pour dire que
même à l'om c'est les orientations qu'on
a prises sont pas les meilleurs qu'eux
il ya des considérations nouvelle à
faire rentrer et ça moi je vous donne
quelques pistes si vous permettez je
peux tout et qu'un jour vous re
téléphoné pour vous dire ce que je pense
en fonction de la conjoncture
mais je pense profondément qu'il vous
faut retrouver la confiance des
agriculteurs etc avec un discours bien
fait on peut y arriver
vous avez à faire une agriculture qui
est formidable vous avez dit c'est la
première d'europe c'est peut-être plutôt
un deuxième roman mais enfin c'est quand
même un joyau formidable qui ne vous
faut pas de gâcher on vous fera que
confiance mais il faut changer le
comportement des pouvoirs publics
merci mon cher collègue s'est donné un
seul ministre a aidé en partie dans vos
réponses et tous les quinze jours vous
pouvez attendre un appel mais je
suggérerais pas l'ensemble des
sénatrices et sénateurs deux appelés
aussi régulièrement
ce qu'on constate c'est deux d'une base
de 500 mille producteurs de lait vous
êtes à 100 milles
on peut imaginer les manifestations sont
moins importantes mais le problème reste
entier
françois marc merci jouets remercié le
brillant et maureen d'avoir voulu
associer les collectes et d'autres
commissions notamment des finances à
cette audition
compte tenu de l'importance du sujet
aujourd'hui et je vais très bref je
crois qu'on peut s'accorder sur
l'objectif que monsieur le ministre
vient de nous et non c'est à savoir
gagner la bataille de la régulation et
d'ailleurs on peut se réjouir que
implicitement dans cette formule on
sous-entend que la dérégulation était
une mauvaise politique et donc on ne
peut que se réjouir de l'objectif qui
est ainsi affichée de reste pour qu'on
puisse tous se mobiliser à ce qu'on soit
d'accord sur ce qu'il ya derrière cette
régulation et j'ai donc deux questions
de ce point de vue parce que évidemment
la question se pose aujourd'hui dans un
contexte où il y a
des discussions sur les rapports de
force au sein de la filière laitière
comme il ya des discussions dans bien
d'autres filières où on a aussi ses
enjeux où chacun essaie de tirer le
maximum
j'ai deux questions la première est ce
que la solution aux milices qui va être
préconisées comportera une baisse de
production laitière est ce que c'est là
dessus que vous envisagez de mettre en
avant des mesures régulatrices utile et
nécessaire et deuxième question quel
sera le rôle qui sera réservé quel
pouvoir pour les agriculteurs dans le
dispositif qui va être suggérées par la
france dès lors que ce qui a été annoncé
ces derniers jours semble-t-il ne reçoit
pas l'agrément de nombreux agriculteurs
puisque il est question de contrats de
fourniture aux laiteries avec selon
certains tendance à une quasi
intégration de certains producteurs
laitiers
ce qui ne semble pas satisfaire nos
agriculteurs beaucoup d'entre eux en
tout cas donc quel est selon vous le
pouvoir qui serait préservé pour le
monde agricole qui aujourd'hui
s'interrogent justement sur la capacité
qu'il aura demain à peser sur les prix
est ce que dans dispositif préconisé
pour la france
on va veiller à ce que le monde agricole
préserve ce pouvoir économique dans la
filière à travers un dispositif qui sera
sans doute parce qu'ils étaient hier
mais qui permettra néanmoins d'avoir une
réponse satisfaisante c'est ce sont les
deux questions qui me paraissent moi
essentiel aujourd'hui au point où en est
la discussion au sein de la profession
merci montréal collecte une mini jeux
vous propose de répondre aux quatre
intervenants et après j'ai en
considérant de parole bien j'espère que
ce n'est pas le rendez vous prévu avant
tard dans la soirée parce que vous avez
ouvert beaucoup de sujets qui sont tous
essentiels mais qui demande évidemment
des discussions approfondies je précise
d'ailleurs qu'on a un moment je le dis
de manière très générale
on est à un moment de l'histoire de
l'agriculture française comme un moment
d'ailleurs de l'histoire
de l'économie européenne ou mondiale où
les choses sont à inventer
donc moi je n'arrive pas avec des
solutions définitives toutes prêtes en
vous disant voilà je mets ça sur la
table ça me paraît la meilleure solution
et puis circulez ya rien à voir on
avance pas à pas et je réponds très
rapidement à françois marque sur ce
sujet je suis passé sur la relation
entre producteurs et industriels d'une
position où il me semblait que le
rapport de force était équilibré mais
n'était pas suffisamment en faveur des
producteurs à une position ce cas je
regarderai plus dans le détail ou les
producteurs ont davantage voix au
chapitre
précisément parce que ça n'a jamais été
fait il faut être très prudents dans la
façon dont on avance pour bien tenir
compte des opinions de tout le monde et
c'est un des aspects importants de la
démarche qui est d'écouter absolument
tout le monde pour être certain qu'on
prend les bonnes décisions et qu'on fait
les bons choix s'agit pas d'appliquer
des recettes du passé
il s'agit d'inventer de nouvelles et
comme toujours ce qu'on invente des
choses nouvelles il vaut mieux écouter
le plus largement possible pour être sûr
de pas faire d'erreur et reconnaître
d'ailleurs lorsque n'est pas dans la
bonne direction être capable d'améliorer
les choses
pour répondre aux remarques de gérard
bailly et pardonnez moi de prendre un
peu de temps pour essayer de rentrer
vraiment dans le fond des sujets que
l'agriculture ne soit pas une production
comme une autre c'est l'évidence les
évidences malheureusement ne sont pas
toujours partagé beaucoup d'états
européens estime que produire du lait ou
produire des vis et des boulons ce la
même chose
c'est un des aspects de la bataille
qu'il faut conduire pour arriver à
mettre en place la régulation quand vous
dites que 1 2 % d'excédent conduisent à
des variations catastrophique des cours
je précise pourra tout à fait concrets
que c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé
et qui expliquent principalement pas
seulement mais principalement la chute
du prix du lait en 2009 dans les années
précédentes notamment en 2008 on avait
eu la conjonction de deux phénomènes
d'une part un problème climatique et
météorologique majeur qui avait affecté
la nouvelle zélande et qui avait conduit
la nouvelle zélande a baissé de
quasiment de moitié sa production de
lait la production de la nouvelle
zélande elle est marginale par rapport à
la production européenne
mais comme il transformé largement en
beurre poudre elle a une incidence sur
les marchés internationaux très forte à
cela c'était conjuguer la chute de la
consommation du lait en chine d'où des
cours qui avaient remonté qui avait
flambé jusqu'à plus de 400 euros la
tonne de lait
l'année suivante plus de problèmes
météorologiques des débouchés qui
explosent en chine
une production qui elle augmente en
nouvelle zélande et des cours qui
s'effondre mais je précise juste que
l'effondrement des cours résulte d'une
variation la production de lait de
l'ordre de 1 8% en nouvelle zélande
sachant que la production européenne
elles étant fixée par quotas n'avaient
pas bougé donc c'est dire la volatilité
des cours et l'importance qu'il ya à
mettre en place une régulation qui
tienne la route sur la d chez crf je
prononcerai pas sur l'administration
d'état je dirai juste quelle est notre
objectif politique
il faut une meilleure organisation des
producteurs de lait et c'est même la
première étape qui doit permettre de
construire la régulation avant même
qu'il y ait des contrats ou des accords
conclus entre industriels et producteurs
il faut que des producteurs de lait soit
mieux organisé entre eux de façon à
mieux défendre leurs intérêts par
rapport aux industriels alors je trouve
un peu surprenant que on nous reproche
une meilleure organisation des
producteurs alors que dans le même temps
au danemark par exemple même si le pays
est évidemment beaucoup plus petit vous
savez que le système repose sur une
seule organisation de producteurs
intégrés à une chaîne industrielle
comment et dans le cadre de la
coopération c'est conforme aux règles de
la concurrence
enfin le résultat est le même donc je
souhaiterais qu'on puisse mieux
organiser les organisations de
producteurs de lait en france et qu'on
trouve les moyens réglementaire ou
législatif pour leur permettre de mieux
s'organiser donc de mieux défendre leurs
intérêts
votre troisième remarque et ça rejoint
des remarques ont été faites par
d'autres de vos collègues monsieur le
président portait sur la question des
prix et des marges
nous avons mis en place à la suite les
décisions de michel barnier de luc
chatel l'observatoire sur les prix et
les marges dans la filière du lait qui a
rendu ses conclusions le 29 juillet les
conclusions sont très claires ce n'est
pas la grande distribution qui fait les
marges les plus importantes sur le lait
ce sont les industriels et les
industriels avec qui j'en ai discuté
tous les industriels de la
transformation laitière jeunes explique
que face à la concurrence à laquelle ils
sont confrontés
ils ont besoin de faire ses marges et de
récupérer le maximum d'argent possible
mais je pense qu'il ya précisément une
marge de manoeuvre est un travail à
conduire pas simplement avec la
distribution mais aussi avec les
industriels je précise également que
j'ai essayé en tout les choix que j'ai
fait jusqu'à présent de faire preuve de
la plus grande cohérence possible
je n'ai pas la vérité révélée j'ai
besoin des conseils de tout le monde et
en particulier des parlementaires mais
aussi les experts mais j'assume les
choix politiques que j'ai fait est juste
au point de vue là je voudrais juste
faire une petite incidence qui répondent
à d'autres questions
d'autres sénateurs sur le choix qui a
été fait du rachat de l'entreprise
entremont par sodiaal
vous savez qu'il y avait deux repreneurs
possibles un repreneur secteu mans privé
qui était lactalis est un autre qui
était un repreneur coopératif qui était
sociale je crois que le choix qui a été
fait qu est un choix difficile sur
lequel nous continuons à avancer mais
qui est soumis à beaucoup de turbulences
est un choix qui permet de constituer un
acteur coopératif fort à côté d'un grand
acteur industriel fort aussi et ce qui
d'ailleurs est une bonne chose pause
exportations françaises et pour les
emplois français qui est lactalis mais
tout ça s'inscrit dans un choix
politique qui est de rééquilibrer les
relations entre producteurs et
industriels du lait en france
s'il n'y avait plus qu'un seul acteurs
industriels du lait en france où un
acteur dominant
comme c'est le cas dans d'autres
filières je pense au port je pense à la
viande est bien pour les producteurs eux
mêmes la situation serait je crois
beaucoup plus difficile sur la question
c'est une petite incidence avait parlé
de la vaccination fc au jeu juge sans
dire un mot parce que c'est un point
évidemment important mon objectif est
d'une part de garantir la santé publique
est d'arriver à éradiquer ce fléau en
engageant une campagne de vaccination
obligatoire parce que je crois que ça
nous permettra de débarrasser de ce
phénomène mais je souhaite que la charge
soit réduite ou nulle pour les éleveurs
et nous travaillons dessus parce que là
où je vous rejoins parfaitement c'est
qu'on peut pas rajouter systématiquement
des contraintes sur les agriculteurs
sans considération de leur activité
économique
c'est la même chose pour la taxe carbone
ou j'ai indiqué que je souhaitais que
l'exonération pour les professions
agricoles soit au minimum de 50% les
arbitrages sont rendus ensuite par le
premier ministre et par le président de
la république
enfin s'agissant la médiation pour
répondre très précisément votre question
elle n'a plus lieu d'être puisque
l'accord a été signé le 3 juin et qu'il
est valable jusqu'à la fin du mois de
décembre l'accord sur les prix et mon
souci constant a été de faire respecter
cet accord par l'ensemble des
industriels et je dois dire que pour le
moment ils ont fait les efforts
nécessaires pour s'y tenir
yannick botrel sur les éléments que vous
avez souligné au début d'autres
interventions
c'est effectivement un point très
important mon souci là aussi constant
dans cette crise et faire en sorte que
on évite au maximum les dérapages en
termes d'ordre public et donc de faire
en sorte de garder un contact avec
toutes les organisations syndicales
représentatives
je les fais samedi j'ai reçu la fnsea
les jeunes agriculteurs la confédération
paysanne la coordination rurale
je le fais régulièrement et j'ai des
contacts quasi quotidien avec les
représentants de l'ensemble de ces
organisations syndicales qui souhaitent
tout j'insiste sur ce point qu'il
souhaite tout trouver une issue à la
crise et qui sont toutes d'accord
pour reconnaître que l'issue ne peut
être que européenne et donc ce qu'ils
attendent même s'ils ont salué les
décisions qui ont été prises hier en
matière de trésorerie parce que je crois
que ça dessert la contrainte financière
des producteurs ce qu'ils attendent
désormais c'est l'assurance que nous ne
nous engagerons pas dans la voie de la
dérégulation totale du marché et je vais
y revenir sur la fin des quotas
je dois juste faire un petit point
d'histoire pour rappeler que la fin des
quotas a été décidé aux accords de
berlin en 1999 en vue d'une élimination
totale des quotas en 2008 et que les
accords de luxembourg 2003 ont confirmé
la suppression des quotas
mais l'on reporté à 2015 donc ce choix
de la dérégulation c'est pas un choix
qui date d'hier ou d'avant-hier
c'est un choix qui était fait
collectivement même si on a repoussé les
choses petit à petit par l'ensemble des
états européens avec une vision qui
aujourd'hui nous paraît daté mais qui à
l'époque paraissait la bonne qui était
il faut toujours gagner en compétitivité
le marché fera la différence entre les
bons et les mauvais et c'est comme ça
qu'on s'en sortira le mieux en matière
agricole
moi je critique personne là dessus parce
que c'est un choix qui appartenait aussi
à l'air du temps à cette idée que la
compétitivité et la concurrence
économique était l'alpha et l'oméga de
toute bonne organisation sociale on en
est revenu aujourd'hui mais je ne
critique personne parce que c'est plus
facile de le dire aujourd'hui que de le
dire hier ou avant-hier le problème et
on est là au coeur de la difficulté
c'est pour ça que je trouve toutes vos
questions particulièrement pertinente
parce qu'elles permettent d'aller au
fond du sujet le problème c'est qu'on ne
renverse pas un choix politique qui date
de 99
c'est à dire de plus de dix ans comme ça
du jour au lendemain le deuxième
problème c'est que ça n'est pas
l'intérêt de certains états européens de
changer de politique
et ça je vous le dis pour le vivre
quasiment tous les jours et pour le
vivre notamment lors des conseils
européens
la bataille et des sévères parce que
notamment les petits états n'ont pas
intérêt à revenir sur la dérégulation
parce que la dérégulation com
expliquer mon homologue néerlandaise
monobloc danoise qui sont des femmes par
ailleurs de très grande qualité
attention de pas stigmatiser qui que ce
soit parce que ces gens là sont de très
grande qualité
ce choix là est un choix qui leur permet
de tailler des croupières à des plus
grands et à queue or l'europe
d'aujourd'hui n'est plus une europe de
trois ou quatre grands d'état et de cinq
petits états c'est une robe de trois ou
quatre grands états et de 23 petits
états et ça ça change la donne et ça
rend la négociation diplomatique plus
compliqué qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière le
mot de régulation ça c'est effectivement
une question majeure
je précise et là je les assume
parfaitement que par stratégie
diplomatique
vous savez que c'est ma formation
d'origine je pense que nous n'avons pas
intérêt à dévoiler toutes nos cartes sur
ce que nous souhaitons en matière de
régulation européenne parce qu'il faut
d'abord constituer la majorité
et une fois que nous avons la majorité
avancé alors que si j'avance trop loin
tout de suite en réclame entre autres la
régulation européenne
personne ne me suivra et je ne serai pas
en mesure de faire bouger les lignes
les choses qui sont certaine c'est que
rien ne sera possible en matière de
régulation sans la réouverture de l'eau
c'est munich est donc l'un des points
majeurs de la négociation c'est la
réouverture de l'eau c'est munich qui me
permet de mettre en place certains
éléments de la régulation tout ça peut
paraître technique mais c'est le fond du
sujet l'organisation commune de marché
ocm qui définit les règles de
concurrence à l'intérieur de la
production de lait de la production
d'ailleurs d'autres produits agricoles
qu'est ce qu'elle dit cette organisation
commune de marché telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui aucune entente entre
industriels des producteurs n'est
possible aucune
elle est possible que dans le cadre
coopératif donc le principe d'accord sur
les volumes et sur des prix entre
industriels et producteurs n'est pas
possible dans le cadre du droit européen
actuel or la régulation à laquelle je
pense repose sur deux piliers essentiels
un pilier nationale dans lequel nous
aurions des accords entre industriels
et producteur sur des volumes et sur les
prix sous le contrôle de la puissance
publique et ces accords devraient être
définis justement dans un cadre
législatif de façon à s'assurer qu'ils
soient les mêmes pour tous qu'ils
garantissent bien les intérêts des
producteurs
le pilier européen doit reposer lui à la
fois sur des mesures d'intervention qui
devrait être consolidée pour être plus
réactive et plus efficace je vous donne
un seul exemple en matière
d'intervention c'est à dire de stockage
privé aujourd'hui le stockage privé
n'est possible que si mois sur 12 or une
peut-être efficace que s'il est
disponible
douze mois sur douze alors c'est un
changement qui paraît mineurs mais qui
là aussi est très important parce que ça
veut dire multiplier par deux les coûts
d'intervention de l'union européenne
mais ça permet aussi de prendre des
décisions de réaction immédiate à la
variation des coûts au lieu de les
pendre avec trois ou quatre mois de
décalage
en attendant construit dans la période
d'intervention possibles deuxième
élément auquel je pense c'est la mise en
place d'un marché à terme du beurre et
de la poudre à l'échelle européenne sous
un contrôle européen parce que le marché
à terme permet de donner la distance par
rapport à la variation des cours et de
stabiliser les cours du beurre et de la
poudre qui sont l'élément de
perturbations numéro un du prix et du
marché aujourd'hui en europe
enfin je n'exclus pas je suis en train
de travailler sur ce que cela voudrait
dire une fois quand je suis prudent pour
des raisons que vous comprendrez qui
sont des raisons d'abord diplomatique
je réfléchis à l'équivalent de ce que
sera la régulation nationales
c'est-à-dire un régulateur européen qui
permettrait de coordonner l'ensemble de
ces mesures est de s'assurer qu'elle se
stabilise bien les prix pour les
producteurs
dernière remarque qu'à fait yannick
botrel il va de soi que j'ai demandé à
toutes les draf d'être mobilisés pour
vérifier que les décisions que nous
avons prises en matière de trésorerie
soit efficace sur le terrain et ne
laisse aucun pour
acteurs de l'aide de côté marcel deneux
vous connaissez le sujet mille fois
mieux que moi
vous avez dit qu'il n'est pas le revenu
agricole n'a marché désorganisé c'est
absolument évident mais je l'affirmé
haut et fort je reprends vos mots mot
pour mot et si vous m'appelez tous les
quinze jours je serai le plus heureux
le plus heureux des ministres de
l'agriculture donc n'hésitez pas à le
faire ça ne me posera aucun problème
vous avez soulevé un sujet qui n'est pas
un sujet négligeable que la question de
la politique génétique du pays qui vous
a pas échappé
pour ceux qui circulent dans les
campagnes il ya tout le monde autour de
cette table que le paysage des vaches
françaises a pas mal évolué en quelques
années et que les prim'holstein ont eu
tendance à remplacer beaucoup de vaches
notamment je le regrette des normandes
chez moi en haute normandie pour une
raison très simple c'est que les
holstein ont un rendement beaucoup plus
élevé que beaucoup d'autres vaches mais
mais elles n'ont pas les mêmes résultats
en termes de qualité nutritionnelle du
lait c'est un autre sujet sur lequel un
poids s'engager mais j'estime que le
camembert du lait
moulé à la louche de normandie
mériterait les produits par du lait de
vache normandie
enfin françois marque sur la bataille de
la régulation déposé deux questions
précises
oui il faut trouver un moyen pour
contrôler la production laitière et
trouver les voies et moyens pour que ces
accords entre industriels et producteurs
permettent aussi d'avoir une visibilité
sur le volume
ça me paraît très important quel pouvoir
pour les agriculteurs alors c'est un
problème majeur
il faut savoir là aussi tirer les leçons
de l'expérience
vous venez d'une région où l'intégration
fait peur et légitimement à tous les
producteurs parce que l'intégration ça
consiste purement et simplement à
transformer des exploitants indépendants
des producteurs indépendants en salariés
industriels or c'est précisément ce
qu'ils veulent éviter il pour répondre
très précisément votre question il ya
des projets de contrats laitiers quand
circuler je ne sais trop comment fournis
par les uns ou par les autres qui sont à
l'opposé de ce que je veux mettre en
place ces contrats stipulaient
exactement où l'alimentation devait être
acheté à quel prix quel était le type
d'installation quelle était la norme de
vache qu'il fallait mettre en place et
ainsi de suite
autrement dit il ne restait plus aucune
marge de manoeuvre pour les exploitants
laitiers pour le producteur
ça ce n'est pas ce que nous souhaitons
faire mais si on veut renforcer les
producteurs une fois encore il faut un
qui s'organise mieux
donc on est une meilleure organisation
des producteurs en aval c'est absolument
essentiel et 2 qu'on fasse très
attention aux paysages industriels
français que nous allons mettre en place
et de ce point de vue là un parfois
reproché de m'occuper trop de la
question d'entremont si je m'en occupe
temps c'est que derrière il ya des
enjeux en matière de pouvoir des
producteurs et des équilibres de la
production de la transformation du lait
en france qui sont absolument majeur
merci monsieur le ministre vous êtes
encore cette table loire poser des
questions
je vous donne l'autorisation de ne poser
uniquement les questions
jean jacques mirassou il sait vais
essayer de me conformer à votre
autorisation monsieur le président je te
rapide monsieur le ministre la
préoccupation immédiate est telle
qu'elle s'exprime aujourd'hui concerne
bien sûr le problème des producteurs et
tout naturellement vous avez fait de
nombreuses reprises allusion aux
relations qui existent entre les
industriels et les producteurs ou
inversement
sauf que dans la problématique tk et
évoqué le grand absent dans le sas qui
devrait figurer conduire à des
producteurs des industriels dans
l'équation tel qu'il est posé c'est le
consommateur est de ce point de vue là
force est de constater que des intérêts
des consommateurs n'ont pas été
tellement abordé dans votre propos est
ma question ressort du constat que tout
le monde peut faire
qu'il s'agisse de l'effondrement du prix
du lait des légumes que sais-je jamais
au niveau du consommateur
on assiste à une révision des prix à la
baisse
quand je dis ça je peux passer également
la viande porcine ou autre ensuite j'ai
bien entendu je vous avais dit
s'agissant du volet qualitatif de ce qui
se passait à l'échelon notre agriculture
à la fois mettant en place des
conditions d'une médiatisation qui
engage sur le plan sanitaire est leur
garantit également des considérations
environnementales tout cela a un coût
comment arrivez-vous à mettre à injecter
ces nouveaux paramètres la danse que
vous avez évoquées vous avez dit à juste
titre que le coût de la main d'oeuvre
peser à concurrence des deux tiers sur
la production des fruits mais que cela
me coûte et est deux fois inférieur
entre madness qui peut être en france
j'aimerais savoir si les conditions
de travail des jeunes et des autres sont
comparables et qu'est ce qu'il peut avec
l'européen expliquer ce différentiel en
terme en termes de rémunération de la
main d'oeuvre est qui qui n'est pas sans
effet bien sûr sur une fine et j'y
reviens ce qui se passe par rapport aux
consommateurs l'an dernier c'était les
fruits et légumes
demain ce sera encore autre chose je
trouve que vous ne pouvez pas dissocier
les consommateurs des relations que vous
avez évoqué entre les producteurs et les
industriels
merci d'enchères collègue alain
chatillon oui monsieur le ministre
3-3 question rapidement la première mais
avoir été un acteur à la tête d'une
entreprise agroalimentaire française
pendant 35 ans je voudrais vous poser la
question de savoir quel est
véritablement aujourd'hui la définition
de la dgccrf
car on a besoin d'y voir clair vous êtes
le mistral alimentation et je crois que
les industriels attendent de savoir ce
que fait à quoi sert la dgccrf
moi j'ai connu la dgccrf et quelques
aider c'est étonnant un interlocuteur
désigné qui apporter des solutions
aujourd'hui il devient de plus en plus
le grand absent et nous avons face à
nous à la fois une réglementation
communautaire qui se met en place à voir
que les industriels ne sont pas informés
ou très éloignées
je pense notamment l'intervention que
l'on a fait avec le président un certain
nombre de collègues sur les profils
nutritionnels récemment et deuxièmement
la fsa qui est en train de véritablement
cannibaliser retiré de sa substance tout
ce qui me semble t'il concernées le
ministère de l'alimentation
alors est ce que demain on va dépendre
du ministère de la santé est ce que
demain il faut mettre en place une
structure pour les industries
agroalimentaires pour le défendre à
bruxelles
je souhaiterais et je vous fais
confiance que le ministère de
l'agriculture reprennent le leadership
sur ces problèmes là le deuxième point
c'est réaffirmer certain nombre de
collègues ici présents font partie de
cette commission sur les pôles de
compétitivité
que véritablement nous avons besoin de
continuer à animer développer les pôles
de compétitivité régionaux
il ne vous a pas échappé que certains
aujourd'hui voudrait constituer un pôle
à vocation mondiale à saclay bon tout ça
c'est très bien mais je rappellerai que
les industries alimentaires c'est la
charpente industrielle des régions et je
ne voudrais pas qu'une fois de plus on
reprenne d'une main ce que la donner
avec une autre niveau la régionalisation
donc là personnellement je souhaiterais
que vous puissiez appuyer la démarche
des pôles de compétitivité régionaux
c'est un facteur de développement le
vois de nombre d'emplois nombre de
travaux et il faut continuer dans cette
voie et le troisième c'est vrai qu'on
parle le contrat de filière et je vous
en félicite c'est une très bonne chose
n'oublions pas au delà du consommateur
la distribution pour avoir pratiqué la
grande distribution pendant 35 ans il ne
m'a pas échappé que quelles que soient
les loi galland et autres on arrivait à
remplacer les marges arrière d'une façon
ou d'une autre personne ici ne
l'ignorent
on a supprimé la loi galland on sait
très bien que aucun industriel n'ira
faire un procès un distributeur son
client qui représente à minima 20% de
son chiffre d'affaires c'est une utopie
mais en revanche on sait très bien dans
l'industrie alimentaire qu'aujourd'hui
ce qui n'est pas donnée en marge arrière
et donné en gratuit alors on s'étonne
mais peut-être faudrait-il regarder de
près ce qui se passe au niveau de la
grande distribution
il y va de l'avenir de nos producteurs
laitiers et d'un certain nombre de pme
dans ce pays
merci ans chez reconnaît claude biver
oui une liste j'ai eu l'occasion de vous
questionner jeudi dernier sur le
problème laitier
vous avez apporté différentes réponses
dont je retrouve une partie 1 ou
négligeable aujourd'hui avec quelques
quelques informations même
supplémentaires j'intervenais ce matin
sur les fruits et légumes
je n'ai pas eu tout à fait une réponse
aussi claire mais dans les deux cas
effectivement j'abordais le problème de
la commercialisation du système évoqué
l'instant et je rappelais détail sur
lequel semi ce même jeudi dernier mais
pas du tout répondu mais répondu la
production sur l'organisation n'est pas
l'organisation de la grande distribution
pas du tout et je rappeler chaque fois
que j'avais déposé une proposition de
loi avait tiré sans réponse qui portait
sur ce thème il y a trois ans au moins
ou quatre ans nous sommes sommes très
patients même dans nos campagnes et et
j'aimerais bien quand même qu'on y
regarde d'un peu plus près car je
constate qu' il ne faudrait pas que la
production y compris les tiers ou même
des fruits et légumes s'organise région
par région
je déplore personnellement êtes en
frontalier de du nord et la belgique la
hollande eux qui sont beaux je vois que
les revendications s'internationalise et
ceux qui crient les plus forts sont pas
forcément ceux qui ont le plus besoin
mais peut quelquefois aussi ceux qui ont
des arrières pensées autre que de que
dit que celle des producteurs faut pas
non plus négliger
alors là dessus nous savons le con je
vous fais confiance sur l'action à
conduire mais j'aimerais vraiment que
nous regardions de très près cette
opération là que nous allions que nous
nous arrêtions pas en tout cas à une
collaboration entre producteurs et
transformateurs parce que de ce côté là
et nous sommes toujours en tant que
producteur le petit poucet dans
l'opération par contre avoir les trois
grands circuits un transformateur certes
mais d'un côté et producteur de notre
côté a remercié les commerçants
commercialisation et bien si aussi se
rapprocher d'une manière très efficace
des consommateurs font sucer là aussi un
point important de notre réflexion notre
démarche précipitée
merci mon sac avec jacqueline panis oui
mais ce ministre j'avais beaucoup de
questions en arrivant pour cette
rencontre mais vous y avez apporté
beaucoup de réponses donc si vous
permettez juste une petite précision ce
pour confirmation voir si j'ai bien
compris je puisse donc relayé cette
information
au cours de la régulation vous avez dit
qu'il ne restait plus que vos amis
italiens il me semble à rencontrer d'ici
peu et dans ce cas vous auriez une
majorité tant que ce qui voudrait dire
que dans la foulée si je me permets vous
envisageriez de convoquer donc ou de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait un conseil
des ministres extraordinaire alors dans
ce cas quel est le calendrier envisagé
s'il vous plaît merci ma chère collègue
jean françois le grand
oui de la même manière ce ministre vous
avez répondu à la question que j'allais
vous posez donc c'est parfait
c'était sur les voies que vous comptiez
emprunter pour aller vers la régulation
et quels étaient les éléments
globalement que vous alliez retenir pour
obtenir cette régulation
vous avez répondu je n'y reviens pas
ceci étant les explications vous avez
donné son som tout à fait intéressante
et est de nature à à être comprise par
l'ensemble des producteurs de lait à une
condition qu'on leur dise mais on
comprend bien même temps que vous soyez
corsetée entre le souci de la diplomatie
et d'avoir des éléments ou des arguments
pour progresser mais il faut pas oublier
quand même le souci d'information
le département de la manche on vous a
interpellé hier vous le savez jean bizet
et et quelques autres collègues parce
que il faut faire savoir
ce ver couvert quoi on va vous répondez
sur le fond à la nature conjoncturelle
que conjoncture structurelles pardon de
la crise et vous répondez aussi sur le
compte l'aspect conjoncturel en
apportant des mesures de court terme
je crois qu'il faut que ça se sache
alors on comprend bien vous ne puissiez
pas en dire plus parce qu'il ya les
exigences que vous avez rappelé mais il
faut quand même en dire suffisamment
pour qu'on comprenne que healy a
effectivement des solutions il ya un
espoir et un avenir il ya un horizon et
dans ce domaine là est d'une manière un
peu subsidiaire on vous a sollicité hier
pour que vous puissiez faire passer ce
message vers tous les producteurs
il y a les organismes les organismes
accrédités les organismes comme moi je
trouve pas un terme et deux mois
représentatif merci c'est ça et il ya
les autres qui ne sont pas dans un
organe et de l'apli pour parler clair
qui n'est pas un organisme représentatif
et pourtant il porte de la désespérance
il porte un certain nombre de
difficultés et est d'une certaine
manière les ont exprimés à regret de
leur part pour faisant peut-être des
erreurs mais il avait il n'avait pas
d'autre solution monte il dit pour
s'exprimer mois je souhaiterais qu'il
n'y ait aucune humiliation
aucune mise à l'écart et que de votre
fête à votre initiative vous puissiez
peut-être prendre contact avec eux je
sais qu'il ya déjà eu des contacts mais
que vous leur donniez peut-être les
éléments de sortie de crise que vous
avez rappelé ici je suis persuadé que ça
permettrait de ramener un peu de
sérénité sachant que ce qui est aussi
grave que la crise conjoncturelle
proprement dit ou sur du structurelles
plutôt proprement dite c'est qu'il y a
une division du monde paysan mais une
division qui est dramatique
elle se vit même au niveau des familles
dans les villages à coup sûr et là je
crois qu'il faut mettre un terme très
rapide à cette division faute de quoi on
n'en souffrira encore pendant un certain
temps on a eu des événements comme ça à
travers l'histoire agricole qui ont pu
diviser le monde agricole sa n'a jamais
était positif merci l'on cherche avec
nathalie goulet
oui monsieur le ministre jean-françois
legrand viens de vous parler de l'apli
jallet j'allais moi aussi vous demander
quelle communication vous alliez faire
car ils sont en basse normandie
peut-être en aussi représentant de tous
ces jeunes qui viennent de s'installer
et qui sont évidemment au coeur du
cyclone en ce qui concerne la production
laitière donc là aussi ma puisque le
président de la république qui était
venu dans l'orne avait avec ses
collaborateurs reçu un certain nombre de
représentants agricoles sauf l'apli qui
n'avait pas voulu recevoir
donc je pense que là aussi il faut
mettre un terme à cette mise à l'écart
de ce syndicat qui est peut-être pas
représentatif d'une façon ou d'une autre
mais qui représente quand même des
centaines et des centaines de jeunes
agriculteurs ça c'est la première
question que je voulais vous
posez la seconde venant de la commission
des affaires étrangères elle sera
peut-être un peu plus exotique mais
c'est litres et des litres et ses
centaines de literie son qui sont jetés
qui sont dispersés alors qu'il ya de la
famine un peu partout j'ai appelé notre
ambassadeur à la fao et je voulais
savoir si dans les moyennes régulation
il y avait des possibilités d'utiliser
ce lait est gâchée à des fins sanitaires
des fins humanitaires
parce qu'il ya un problème moral aussi
qui se pose et qui a été soulevé à de
nombreuses reprises
c'est vrai que tout ce lait déversé pose
un certain nombre de problèmes aussi je
sais que ce n'est pas simple enfin
puisque vous êtes en face de moi je me
permets de poser la question merci
françois patriat peut être très
brièvement aussi une seule ministre
moi je suis heureux de voir aujourd'hui
cette unanimité autour de la régulation
elle n'a pas toujours été d'actualité
j'ai vécu 84 et la mise en place des
quotas ou les éleveurs me disais chaque
jour laissé aux agriculteurs le droit de
produire
ils seront faire le marché bon on va pas
revenir en arrière
la question elle rejoint sous de madame
boulet monsieur le ministre
d'abord elle montre que dans les
productions françaises à chaque fois que
les productions sont adoucies et des
signes de qualité
ces problèmes de marché ne se pose pas
on l'a vu pour moi aujourd'hui
comment son protégé je dis pas pour les
bourguignons mais d'éleveurs franc
comtois tous les éleveurs qui font du
lait qui font du morbier derrière ne
connaissent pas la crise aujourd'hui
c'est une septième aujourd'hui moi
aujourd'hui c'est vrai donc c'est vrai
je le vois aussi est le paradoxe c'est
que les zones qui font des fromages a
aussi aujourd'hui manque de lait non de
l'est parce qu'on est elle plus de
jeunes dans les où il manque de lait bon
c'est une réflexion mais je rejoins ce
que dit à l'instant ma collègue
vous avez parlé de l'oci à munich
monsieur ministre moi je voudrais parler
de l'om c est ce que la solution tout
problème agricole
tous marchés confondus aujourd'hui ne
passe pas par le fait qu'il faille
sortir de ma l'agriculture de l'om c'est
est-ce que la grille que je m'en suis
entretenu avec avec pascal lamy à deux
reprises il n'est pas lui favorable et
j'ai eu des différends avec lui est ce
que au delà des des pistes sur la
régulation que vous avez évoquées sont
des pistes auquel je souscris qui sont
des pistes auquel je souscris
pistes européennes selon l'osce et à
munich qui souscrit reste qu'au delà il
faut pas laisser me sens bien sur des
mesures à long terme
et aujourd'hui il ya plus le stockage il
ya plus les restitutions
il n'y a plus et privat l'exportation
quand les quotas sont enlevés et que les
finances publiques sont à mal c'est
difficile d'apporter des solutions
immédiates dans les perspectives à fixer
au monde agricole
est-ce que la sortie de l'agriculture de
l'om c'est n'est pas une idée que nous
pourrions avancer en commun
merci on sert greg une proposition d'un
ancien ministre de l'agriculture
pauvre à all with on a déjà dit beaucoup
de choses simplement
je vais témoigner que dimanche chez moi
c'était le fait du parc naturel régional
et c'est la fête du lait il y avait donc
que 20000 personnes 150 vaches laitières
des holstein des normandes des bleus et
avec un beau concours il a pu quand même
avoir lieu mais j'ai eu le droit à une
belle manif de l'apli avec 40 tracteurs
qui ont déversé 700 mille litres de lait
dans un champ à à côté de ma commune ça
s'est passé à peu près bien je dis rien
mais ça veut dire qu'effectivement le
monde agricole est extrêmement divisé
parce que cette fête du lait en clair je
la fais que la fnsea majoritaire bien
sauf que à la sortie de la ville à y
avait des minoritaires et beaucoup
d'agriculteurs de la fnsea qui avait
rejoint le pli dans la manifestation
un tel prix dans les chambres et culture
a eu beau dire qu'il était contre la
manif n'empêche qu'à la fin des fins il
est venu assister au déversement du lait
parce que ben parce que la situation
était socialement difficile et pour des
secteurs comme l'avesnois ou d'état des
éleveurs ne peuvent faire que de
l'élevage 1 c'est-à-dire au clair on
veut pas retourner un dans le schiste
les télés les terres la situation est
dramatique c'est à dire que les mesures
rapides dont vous avez parlé est ce
qu'elles sont suffisants parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya bien un tiers des
éleveurs qui sont dans le rouge à dire
qu'ils ont des dettes qui n'arrivent
plus à payer le contrôle laitier par
exemple un qui n'arrivent plus à payer
leurs fournisseurs
et là c'est vraiment dramatique des
jeunes que quiros qui ont témoigné
devant le public les uns après les
autres ils pleuraient franchement je
m'assure qu'il pleurait et c'était
c'était pas des discours de circonstance
ils sont dans le noir
donc il y a urgence à réagir monsieur le
ministre je suis pas de la compassion et
du catastrophisme
c'est la réalité vraie mais j'ai cru
comprendre à travers propos que vous la
vivez vous aussi chez vous et donc ils
vraiment il ya une urgence deuxièmement
sur les problèmes structurels de la
régulation
bon on veut peut appeler ça quotas
laitiers ok mais au bout du compte ça
sera bien une régulation vous pouvoir
garantir un volume à produire avec un
certain prix garantissant un revenu
enfin alors je sais bien c'est difficile
chez moi un délai les plus gros
agriculteurs ceux qui à l'éleveur qui
avait plus d'un million de de quotas ils
ont créé ingénieux et puis quelques
années y vendait le relais aux belges
plus cher plus cher sauf qu'aujourd'hui
alors là évidemment le prix s'est
complètement effondrée et c'était eux
évidemment qu'ils étaient les meneurs de
l'apli alors même qu'ils avaient fait un
bras d'honneur aux coopératives du coin
il ya deux ou trois ans ah parce qu'ils
aiment à nous en belgique 15 on est
mieux payé
sauf qu'aujourd'hui ils sont dans la 1
n'avait compris donc il faut que la
régulation elle soit française mais
elles soient européennes parce que ceux
qui étaient avec leur gros quotas et
aujourd'hui ils sont les meneurs de
l'opep des opérations quoi hein donc il
faut qu'on arrête bien une maîtrise de
la production par rapport à la
consommation et la consommation des
produits laitiers vendus globalement
yaourts et autres elles n'augmentent pas
elle a plutôt tendance à diminuer donc
il faut bien réguler
et il faut bien vivre certains secteurs
augmenter certains d'autres diminue donc
il faut bien régulé et quand vous me
dites il faut essayer de maîtriser les
industriels chez moi y'a lactalis 1 et
il ya eu au play candia ya les deux
savent et les prix sur les mêmes il
donne les mêmes prix aux éleveurs de la
même région
donc ya pas vraiment concurrence entre
les deux il ya la lier à la même offre
donc il faut vraiment que l'on trouve un
moyen qui soit peu qui s'appellera plus
et quotas laitiers mais de toute manière
un moyen de maîtriser la production par
rapport à la consommation
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui il faut
pouvoir diori culteurs hockey les prix
vont augmenter mais la production elle
devra diminuer et selon quel mode quel
rythme les choses pourront elles se
faire bien monsieur le ministre entend
d'une plus parler de maîtrise parler
seulement d'adéquation entre la
production et la consommation
oui jean boyer c'est le dernier
intervenant winch ministre il est
inutile de leur dire tout haut que le
les îles salaires des éleveurs et
particulièrement en de manta nous en
sommes tous convaincus que le ministre
ne pensez vous pas que la meilleure
régulation puis que c'est un mot fort
qui a été prononcé depuis le début de
cette rencontre se serait d'abord le
maintien des quotas parce que s'il n'y
avait pas eu le maintien des quotas dans
quelles situations seront nous serions
nous aujourd'hui de deuxième question et
je m'arrêterai là vous avez évoqué la
production améliorer de nouvelle zélande
donc je sais que c'est facile à dire
quand on est autour d'une table surtout
ici au sénat est il envisageable une
régulation mondiale de la production
laitière
merci mon cher collègue féministe vous
propose de répondre aux interventions
auxquelles vous n'auriez pas répondu
dans la première partie
bien merci pour toutes ces questions
supplémentaires
une seule chose dont tous ces propos qui
sont tous intéressants utile et qui
permettent d'avancer dans notre
réflexion commune
il ya une seule chose à laquelle je ne
souscris pas c'est quand on me dit qu'il
ya urgence à agir comme si je restais de
mon bureau les bras croisés à mon
journal toute la journée
je veux juste dire qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de décisions fortes
qui ont déjà été prises notamment celles
qui ont été prises hier le progrès sur
la régulation européenne tout ça
représente un travail considérable
depuis plusieurs semaines jean jacques
mirassou sur la préoccupation majeure
qui étaient là coût de revient du
producteur
moi je crois que le point essentiel
auquel il faut que nous parvenions c'est
arrivé à un prix du lait qui permettent
de couvrir le coût de revient du
producteur tout en gardant évidemment en
perspective
l'intérêt des consommateurs mais la
priorité absolue et je crois qu'il faut
toujours prendre un fil pour démarrer
c'est de faire en sorte que le coût de
revient les producteurs soient couverts
si vous ne garantit ses passagers y
compris d'ailleurs de manière
législatives
ensuite c'est ce qu'ils sont les plus
forts c'est-à-dire des producteurs les
industriels qui vont s'en sortir le
mieux
donc je crois que ça ça doit être la
priorité numéro un
quitte ensuite à ce qu'on adapte les
choses niveau de l'industriel du
distributeur mais je vais vous dire le
distributeur il a de toute façon le
consommateur en face de lui
donc il est bien obligé de vendre son
produit et s'il peut tirer le prix vers
le bas il réduira sa marge
je pense qu'il faut commencer d'abord
par garantir le coût de revient du
producteur
je précise quand même que au 1er octobre
la réunion que j'ai engagé sur
ce sujet des contrats entre industriels
et producteurs et de la filière du lait
les associations de consommateurs
participeront à la table ronde que j'ai
organisé sur la question du différentiel
de main d'oeuvre fruits et légumes par
rapport à nos autres partenaires
européens
toute la difficulté pour nous et que
nous ne pouvons pas partir de la même
base sociale et du même consensus social
et c'est un problème qu'on retrouve
évidemment dans d'autres secteurs
l'allemagne par exemple en matière de
fruits et légumes n'a pas de salaire
minimum
elle n'a pas de salaire minimum il est
évident que pour nous en france et hors
de question d'améliorer la compétitivité
de quelques filières que ce soit en
transgressant la règle du salaire
minimum en deuxième lieu elles emploient
davantage de ressortissants venus d'état
mans notamment de la pologne et en
troisième lieu ces ressortissants n'ont
pas de charges sociales du tout puisque
ils sont embauchés sur la base de leur
protection sociale du pays d'origine
donc tout ça fait un différentiel de
coût de compétitivité très important en
faveur d'autres pays
nous nous devons inventer autre chose
parce qu'il n'est pas question qu'on
s'aligne sur ce modèle là c'est là que
ça rend les choses plus compliqué mais
je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous avons bien
avancé notamment sur l'augmentation des
exonérations de charges patronales
monsieur chatillon sur la dgccrf je
rejoins à vos propos je note bien ce qui
a été dit
que l'objectif du ministère
l'agriculture ça ne prend le leadership
sur ces problèmes là c'est très clair et
nous ferons le nécessaire pour arriver à
prendre le leadership d'en parler que
monsieur novelli aujourd'hui je lui ai
indiqué que je souhaitais effectivement
que l'on fasse attention à remettre les
choses decker et que ce soit d'abord
l'intérêt des producteurs et le limousin
agriculture qui soit privilégiée avant
les questions administratives droit de
la concurrence sur les pôles de
compétitivité régionaux on a eu
l'occasion d'en parler ensemble moi je
suis très favorable à ce qu'on renforce
épaules et est-ce qu'on favorise les
regroupements nécessaire pour gagner en
compétitivité en face à la distribution
là aussi eu l'occasion d'en parler
oui bien entendu il faut faire attention
à mieux contrôler les différentes
pratiques qu de bee ware je vais essayer
d'être un peu plus explicite avec vous
sur la question la commercialisation
notamment dans ces tordus l'émotion à
secteur des fruits et légumes
je pouvoir l'être parce que nous avons
la discussion aujourd'hui je vois les
distributeurs très régulièrement
aujourd'hui nous aurons une discussion
de près trois heures avec eux sur ces
différents sujets là je leur ai demandé
de faire un effort sur rabais remises et
ristournes
vous savez que c'est une pratique le
connaissais tout ce qui consiste à
demander une remise supplémentaire aux
producteurs de fruits et légumes en
échange d'un service qui est rendue par
la grande distribution
quand il est rendu là j'ai souhaité que
face à la crise importante dans la
filière des fruits et légumes il puisse
renoncer pour les semaines à venir à
cette pratique des rabais remises et
ristournes ce qui serait un geste
significatif et volontaire de la part la
grande distribution vis-à-vis les
producteurs de fruits et légumes
premiers éléments
deuxième élément je souhaite que sur les
accords de marge là aussi on regarde ce
qu'il est possible de faire pour
améliorer les choses je vis à vis des
producteurs dans les semaines à venir
troisième élément est là nous avons un
accord entre tous les acteurs de la
filière c'est un point important je
souhaite supprimer dans la loi de
modernisation de l'agriculture
tous les accords non écrits entre
producteurs grossistes et distributeurs
parce que ces accords n'ont écrit il
consiste à faire venir la marchandise
sans que l'on sache quel prix va
recevoir le producteur je pense qu'il
faut substituer à ce système verbale qui
se fait au détriment des producteurs
un système de contrats écrits dont le
principe devrait être défini par la loi
de modernisation de l'agriculture
ça ça me paraît un point aussi très
important enfin sur le rapport de force
je veux juste rappeler la nécessité
impérative qu'il ya à mieux organiser
les exploitations
nous avons trois cent mille
exploitations au total en france
nous avons dix mille industries
agroalimentaires et nous avons sept
distributeurs
donc le rapport de force forcément est
favorable à ceux qui sont les moins
nombreux jacqueline panis sur la
question de la négociation européenne
nous en sommes aujourd'hui à 238 voix
pour avoir la majorité qualifiée il faut
255 voix
l'italie pèse 29 voix donc si l'italie
se joint à notre mouvement mais il faut
encore et y était extraordinairement
réticentes au départ nous aurons la
majorité qualifiée de 267 voix
pourquoi est ce que cette majorité
qualifiée est décisive elle est décisive
parce que ensuite lorsque vous réunissez
le conseil et qu'il faut prendre une
décision vous savez que la pratique
européenne c'est qu'on ne vote jamais ça
se fait pas consensus
mais chacun sait aussi qu'à les rapports
de force donc une fois qu'on sait que le
rapport de force défavorable la
régulation là vous pouvez convoqué votre
conseil et avant une réunion qui se
passe plus facilement
je précise juste que j'ai fait cette
proposition lundi avec son homologue
polonais de convocation d'un conseil des
ministres extraordinaire mais que la
décision appartient exclusivement à la
présidence en exercice de la présidence
suédoise qui évidemment a refusé
mais je pense qu'il faut la mettre sous
pression jusqu'à ce qu'elle accepte je
n'ai aucun doute aucun doute sur la
légitimité aujourd'hui d'un conseil des
ministres à la culture je ne
comprendrais pas que face à la crise que
nous connaissons qui est grave dans tous
les pays européens les ministres de la
culture ne se réalise pas on a demandé
lundi la réponse a été négative je
persuadé que nous arriverons à renverser
la tendance
jean françois legrand sur la question et
ça d'une question qui a été posée par
beaucoup de personnes sur la question de
la souci d'information des producteurs
moi je note cela je crois que c'est très
important effectivement qu on l
information la plus large possible pour
leur montrer qu'il ya une perspective et
je suis persuadé je vais vous dire c'est
un peu paradoxal je peux être moins
inquiet pour la filière du lait que pour
d'autres filières parce que la
consommation de lait des produits
laitiers elle est relativement stables
relativement stable que l'impact sur la
santé sur l'évolution notamment des
enfants il est reconnu et donc ça fait
un produit qui est valorisant et que les
consommateurs souhaitent consommer il
évolue beaucoup dans la consommation des
différents produits laitiers à la
production et la consommation de fromage
augmente fortement celles de produits
les frais baissent notamment du lait uht
acheter mais globalement la consommation
de produits lactés reste stable
donc je n'ai pas d'inquiétude sur le
débouché donc il faut absolument que
nous arrivions effectivement faire
passer cette idée que toute notre
politique elle est là pour stabiliser
les marchés et garantir un revenu
équitable aux producteurs de lait essart
fera passer les messages sur l'appli
quelle est la politique que j'ai suivie
jusqu'à présent
d'abord je les ai vus à rennes et mon
directeur de cabinet les a reçus
officiellement à paris j'ai fait un
choix qui est
de recevoir régulièrement tout je dis
bien tout parce que ça n'a pas toujours
été des usages les organisations
syndicales représentatives du monde
agricole et leur part de l'activité dans
les syndicats agricoles est définie
comme de n'importe quel autre syndicat
de salariés en france
s'il parlement souhaite demande
explicite moins fortement que le
ministre l'agriculture reçoivent l'appli
mois une fois encore je suis là pour
écouter vos propositions et vos
remarques progresser dans les
propositions que je mets sur la table
je n'y vois pas d'obstacle majeur
nathalie goulet sur la question des
jeunes
c'est probablement vous avez tout à fait
raison ceux qui souffrent le plus
aujourd'hui
vous connaissez là aussi tous les
producteurs de lait de cette table la
situation le jeune qui a 22 23 ans j'en
ai vu beaucoup qui reprennent
l'exploitation
quand une charge financière très l'eau
sur le dos en général l'exploitation n'a
pas été mise aux normes
donc ils font les frais d'investissement
et de mise aux normes c'est de l'ordre
de 260 milles à 250000 euros en fonction
de la taille de l'exploitation parfois
c'est beaucoup plus ça fait une charge
financière très lourde c'est pour cela
que j'ai demandé aux banques que les
prêts qu'ils vont accorder avant le mois
de décembre privilégie avant tout les
jeunes parce que c'est là que nous avons
une vraie différence philosophique avec
la commission européenne
c'est que je ne crois pas que le marché
fait le tri entre les bons et les
mauvais je pense au contraire que ce que
nous voyons concrètement sur le terrain
c'est que la crise frappe d'abord ceux
qui ont fait des investissements d'abord
ceux qui se sont modernisés et d'abord
ceux qui se sont mis des charges sur le
dos alors sur la possibilité d'utiliser
le lait des fins humanitaires moi je
perçois très bien la tension qu'il y
avait derrière qui est juste tout le
problème c'est celui la
commercialisation du transport de la
collecte et du coup de tout cela mais on
peut le évaluer c'est pas quelque chose
d'impossible
françois patriat on a déjà eu l'occasion
de discuter de ça ensemble
sur la question de l'om c'est la seule
chose que je peux dire c'est que nous
sommes allés à l'extrême limite des
concessions acceptables en matière
agricole dans l' omc et le problème sur
l'om sait c'est que nous avons fait des
concessions à un moment où la situation
de crise sur le marché agricole n'était
pas aussi pressante qu'elle est
aujourd'hui et je vous cache pas que sur
ce sujet j'ai certaines inquiétudes
paul raoult est ce que les mesures
seront suffisantes
on fera en tout cas le maximum j'ai
demandé au draft de suivre ça au jour le
jour pour faire en sorte que nous soyons
assurés qu'en matière de report de
cotisations de nouveaux prêts qui seront
mis en place cela suffise pour les
exploitants laitiers
j'envoyais sur la meilleure régulation
et sur la question du maintien des
quotas je veux peut-être en profiter
enfin tout petit point rapide sur le
sujet dans la ligne d'ailleurs du
rapport qu'avait fait jean boyer sur
jean bizet pardon sur la question du
lait mon obsession depuis des semaines
et depuis le mois de juillet depuis que
je suis arrivé à ce poste
et dès le mois de juillet j'ai dit et
répété qu'il y avait une crise du lait
l'une des premières réunions que j'ai
fait me saada gris culture est une
réunion avec l'ensemble des acteurs de
la filière du lait j'ai pas attendu que
les événements se dégrade pour mesurer
la gravité de la situation
j'ai fait un choix dès le départ on a
parlé là aussi avec jean bizet et qu'un
certain nombre d'entre vous qui était de
ne pas revenir sur les quotas
pourquoi parce que je pense que l'on ne
progresse notamment en matière de
diplomatie que si on est capable de
montrer qu'on évolue dans sa position
et si la france était à regoûter sur les
quotas toujours dans sa logique
d'opposition et de minorités bloquantes
nous aurions été battus nous aurions été
battu j'ai demandé je vous
10 à titre d'exemple et de prof très
concrète j'ai demandé le gel de
l'augmentation de 1% des quotas pour
2010 nous avons été quatre états à
soutenir ses propositions 4 une fois
encore pour une raison très simple comme
explique tous mes interlocuteurs c'est
que les quotas fige un état des choses
qui est défavorable aux petits états et
donc ils le refusent plus quelques
grands états comme l'italie par exemple
qui estime qu'au contraire plus
produisent mu ce portrait qui ne veulent
pas être prisonnier de quotas donc je
crois que c'est plus intelligent de
dépasser cela en disant d'accord les
quotas on laisse tomber
c'était décidé on revient pas sur une
décision il ya un aspect psychologique
aussi là dedans
si vous demandez aux gens de revenir sur
une décision qu'ils ont prise
si vous demandez à la commission de
revenir ses missions qu'ils ont prises
ou lui fait perdre la face vous les
prenez bille en tête
il se braque et 10 tailles s est encore
les français qui viennent nous embêter
et finalement on n'obtient rien je pense
qu'il est plus habile de dépasser ça en
mettant en place une régulation
européenne des marchés dont on construit
les éléments petit à petit et dont on
montre que cela peut être plus
intelligente et plus efficace
petit à petit on n'est pas loin de
gagner la bataille
moi j'aurais terminé par là en vous
disant que on a de toute évidence perdu
la première manche sur la dérégulation
on a eu un vent de dérégulation complet
dans tout le monde agricole notamment
dans le monde les ti dont on voit les
conséquences aujourd'hui
moi je vous dis aujourd'hui ce soir
solennellement que nous ne sommes pas
loin de gagner la deuxième manche
nous sommes à quelques voix de gagner la
deuxième manche et de ce point de vue là
le soutien des parlementaires et les
propositions des parlementaires pour
affiner tous ces projets essayer de
tomber sur la proposition la plus juste
que seront naturellement précieux mais
merci monsieur le ministre
sur le dernier point que vous avez
évoqué je partage tout à fait votre
approche puisque nous avons eu
l'occasion d'en parler longuement
voulais vous remercier sur les pour les
réponses que vous nous avez apporté et
le débat que ça nous a permis
d'organiser crois qu'à travers la crise
des tiers on a abordé globalement la
problématique de l'agriculture française
dans le cadre de la politique agricole
commune
merci pour les réponses conjoncturelles
que vous avez pu faire vis-à-vis des
agriculteurs mais merci aussi des
perspectives que vous nous trace près
dans la loi de modernisation de
l'agriculture et je crois qu'à partir de
là nous pourrons apporter des réformes
structurelles à notre agriculture pour
les c'est quand même un avenir pour ces
jeunes qui s'installent avec une très
bonne formation et qui sont de
véritables professionnels merci monsieur
le ministre nous avoir consacré près de
deux heures vous venez de suivre
l'audition de bruno le maire le ministre
de l'agriculture par la commission de
l'économie sur la crise laitière pour
revoir cette audition notre site
internet publicsenat.fr merci de votre
fidélité et à très bientôt sur notre
antenne